one of the joyous things about being a
crossdresser and a martial artist
is i probably chad's actually when i was
younger jocks and the kind of dudes who
wanted to fight
they would come and they would want to
fight the crossdresser straight away of
course
right since i'm a martial artist right
it's a beautiful thing
when a man in a skirt knocks out a chat
with a jumping spin kick that's a thing
of beauty
you just get chun-li on there exactly it
was good it was good
okay so like that's the other thing i
wanted to ask as well is about like the
the martial arts because i don't think
we got like fully into how
you developed or you decided to kind of
do that as like a
[Music]
so obviously you know you grew
appreciation towards wrestling through
watching wwe
yeah stuff like that right so is that
kind of the same thing with martial arts
as well oh with martial arts i um you
know i was i
took an interest in it from a young age
you know i think like probably like
potentially you and yourselves were
bullied a lot as a child
younger sibling i'm an older sibling i'm
the mother
i am an only child
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm three in the lineup of four oh so
yeah i'm same yeah
we both got red beards oh me and connor
hey
connor beard you're basically
it's like the pokemon evolution
i could see the meme on reddit already
you take one of your cosplay videos
it's evolving
[Laughter]
uh anyway martial arts bullied a lot and
i liked the karate kid movies
you got boys yeah man that was a i was a
fat kid
no one's ripped in school yeah except
that one kid who's really thin in his
abs [ __ ] that kid
i could suck eat pizza drinks beer all
day still got his six pounds
somehow's abs right right god they said
god doesn't have favorites [ __ ] man
so what like martial arts did you take
i started in taekwondo and then i went
into capoeira
oh wow then i went into muay thai and
then from there the floodgates opened i
even did jeet kune do
kali freestyle grappling hub
where'd you find the time to do that how
long does it take to learn a martial
arts or did you just like dabble in it
and
learn to well you know i mean it's um i
hear that that's not good sorry
that was bad broadcasting that's okay
it's all good um
no you start training it's like the
thing about training is it's just the
thing that you do isn't it it's like
yeah i started training taekwondo they
had taekwondo at school
and so then on friday after school was
the thing that i did just went to
taekwondo because
yeah but you also listed off about like
nine different types of marketers
every single martial arts start training
and you you know
develops your skills and you develop an
interest yeah and so then you get
exposed to other martial arts right and
you say that looks interesting
looks interesting because you have a
space of comparison now
with what you're learning and what they
seem to be learning so now you can say
all right well that looks
interesting it looks like something that
could help with what i'm trying to
achieve
right right so then you kind of end up
expanding right so what would you say is
like your
favorite type i guess or like one that
you learn from the most like taekwondo
is my first love
you know so that's kind of the one and
also because i did it when i was the
youngest it's the one that stuck in my
body the most easily how young were you
when you did take one
start at 13 13 okay yeah and this is the
thing like i got flexible
before i became a teenager and my
flexibility was naturally taken away
right that's allowed me to stay flexible
i can still do the high kicks and the
splits
splits yeah oh my god i'll do them on
this table if you want
no that's why i added if you want
um yeah so yeah so uh yeah it started in
taekwondo i can't remember the rest of
the question
just just wondering what i'm starting
yeah martial arts i mean
it's i wonder is there like a scale of
like this martial art is more useful
than this one right
now because i've seen in like a bunch of
other stuff that there's just so many
martial arts that seem like they're like
almost i actually are fake or like that
they're not you know that
is that controversial to say i don't
know if that's well look this
debate has raged in the martial arts
community it's really okay
so this is everyone has an opinion on
this and now that we've got you know
competitive mixed martial arts everyone
the consensus seems to be muay thai for
your striking brazilian jiu-jitsu for
your grappling
but then you got to understand as well
that's sport in a cage when there are
rules
right so then in if there's no rules if
you're in war
or self-defense in the street or
something then you have systems like
krav maga which is all based around
murder basically right right so like
there are other styles like a particular
kung fu styles where you never do
anything except
strike the eyes and the throat and the
groin you know that's literally all you
do in the whole jesus
so not just there's no in my opinion
there's no best system or anything it
just depends what you're doing with it
right right and there are the different
you know different round pegs to fit in
around holes and square pegs for square
holes
you ever done mma uh i've trained mma i
haven't fought i was actually interested
in fighting we were to do it a couple
years ago i actually started training
for it
oh really finally found a thing this man
hasn't done yet
i started training for it but it just
became apparent that it was like on a
on a cost-benefit ratio she was really
yeah
it wasn't really good well there's a lot
that goes into it right i was gonna need
a good
two years of consistent training to
properly get my skills back
right yeah to where they need to be for
fighting but then also you got to
consider okay so what weight am i gonna
fight at
am i gonna do a big weight cut let's say
i do that then afterwards okay well now
that's going to affect my wrestling
because now i'm skinny
but then also let's say i do the fight
and it goes well
when then what does that really lead to
more opportunities to fight
i don't really want to be a professional
fighter you know
but now i've organized my whole life for
that sake right
so you know and yeah and like
and that's if the fight goes well if the
fight goes badly i just i can perfect
i need plastic surgery you know i
probably might need to go back home
you know so yeah you trained for two
years to get publicly beaten up right
right right right right
that's tough yeah so i thought about it
actually i trained mma and i really
liked the training
i was i was interested in fighting
what's like the difference between
training mma and training just a normal
martial arts um
well mma it's everything mixed together
right right but also you have
you've done so many already right so
yeah but you've got quite a specific
like rule set in mma that must be
followed you know you're fighting in
either a cage or a ring right so it's
built for that environment so in mma you
do a lot of work against
walls so there's a lot of grappling
against walls because you naturally have
a wall that you're going to meet at some
point
and you can't go further than that right
right but then you know if you were
fighting
in the desert that would not be the case
right
so it's a specific rule set so you train
for that rule set and for the skill set
required for that environment
whereas like if you're going to do like
street self-defense or something
depends on what attitude do you want
cause i've always wanted to get into
martial arts but i
i didn't know which martial arts to
start with basically because
they're training yeah sure is there like
a is there i guess like a
kind of a difficulty or is that like i
assume you know
well no no there's so much difficulty
well
it's more like you know like you want to
test the button what is like that what
is like the easiest type of martial arts
to get into if you have like
no prior knowledge in it because i
assume there are some martial arts where
it's like
you need to have some base level of
martial arts because they're all
systems and so when you start training
the system you start at the beginning
right right so no one's gonna put you so
there's no like type of martial art
where it's like you need to have like
prior knowledge of there's no there's no
10-hit combo that you need to know
there would be for particular like
particular forms
not the art itself particular training
environments like if you want to go to
this guy's school you need to have 10
years experience or whatever
ah okay but not for the art itself no
right right
straight up if you're jumping into you
know expert level when you're a beginner
then you're just making a silly decision
honestly